for some it was the highlight of the
ceremony arousing conclusion to Barack
Obama's inauguration it looked real
enough
Beyonce belting out the star-spangled
banner like few can but the music people
were hearing wasn't live the US Marine
Band is confirmed to Sky News that it
was miming to the national anthem and
Beyonce was lip-synching to a recording
that they made earlier Beyonce decided
not to sing live just minutes before
going on a spokesman for the United
States Marine Band said we don't know
why it's not because Beyonce can't sing
we all know Beyonce can sing we all know
the Marine Band can play all
inauguration performers pre-record a
version just in case something
unexpected stops and performing live
Beyonce's released these photos of her
recording but not commented yet or
explained why she chose to lip-sync on
Washington's now some were shocked by
the news what will you say if I told you
that she was lip-syncing she wasn't
actually singing yesterday I wouldn't
believe it I thought she was going to
laugh on my own voice not a recorder so
it surprise you to hear that she was
lip-syncing yeah unbelievable so they
should just do it right and be truthful
and do all right
others were unmoved
we're just happy that they chose her to
sing the star-spangled banner for our
president the music you don't to hear me
sing all the other performances in the
inauguration were live Beyonce's reasons
are still a mystery
her performance dividing Americans
between the outraged and indifferent who
says what she sounded like that matters
live or not
Domenic Waghorn Sky News Washington